what's going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are here to watch the official trailer
for The Little Mermaid join with someone
who we don't really do any videos together
hey John how are you I'm good it's nice to
see you how are you good took a break from
the Oscars to come here yes I did how you
liking it I don't I'm not watching I don't
really care you're really missing out they're
nailing it I heard a couple of the wins and I
was like all right I make this one this
one bothered me a little bit but anyway
uh no seriously jamaicers that's ridiculous
let's see what they have a whole argument
about that right now let's see this trailer's
all of power and uh yeah leave a like people
whoa oh is this when Ariel saves him yeah
it must be gor verbinsky's Little Mermaid
yes it is
broke the rules hello the above
World a man was drowning I had to
save him this obsession with humans has
to stop Javier Bart dance I had no idea
so she's a mixed ethnicity I can help
you you can't live in that world unless
you become a human yourself is that
even possible that's what I live for
it's got the laugh down oh yeah The Voice
something about you seems different I can't
quite figure it out you idiot oh my goodness
got a lady Scuttle and anthroporifically
corrects her biologically correct crap
oh my God
serious Aquaman Vibes yeah I know he's a human
you're a mermaid that doesn't make us enemies
Kiss the Girl
hey we got the fireworks in there that's nice
are we wow we gotta we gotta skim that trailer
yeah here in that party I caught this video I want
to say her name's like hi Jamie or hey Jamie or
she did Part of Your World with this like creepy
Snapchat filter now whenever I hear that song I
think of that video good good that's probably some
of the technology they use to bring all of this
to life all right first order of business we gotta
just check out I forget the seagull's name so
there's Scuttle yeah so they made it a girl yeah
it sounds like Aquafina oh is it Aquafina yeah I
think so she got that rasp yeah yeah you might be
right not my Scuttle I'm not gonna lie Sebastian
threw me way off yes yeah absolutely I'm still
wrapping my mind that's a little disturbing it
was really disturbing very much distracted by that
um I had no idea that that's what they were
going to be going for here yeah because this
this has there's something strange about the
visuals to me where you have this mixture where
it's like all right you're fully embracing
the fantasy side of it you know like Javier
Bardem and this King Trident outfit and
then they're like let's go super freaking
real now look at the animals and have them
talk let's get that Lion King Technology in
here and that's the part that was really is so
jarring to me did you see that yeah I think it
especially for a movie like this that still
wants to remain a pretty locked in fantasy
I am curious to see how that will affect
the tone overall because Sebastian is such
an important and endearing character such an
animated character yeah like he's not for me
that sounds stupid he's a very expressionist
character yeah so to see him it's so funny
when you first see it maybe it'll work within the
the context of it um I I like the look of the cast
so far I don't know any I don't know who's playing
Prince Eric I don't know who this guy is um he's
really hot whoever he is he's really hot Rob
Marshall who did the fourth Pirates movie makes
sense why this kind of does have some on Stranger
Tides Vibes and on Stranger Tides did feature
mermaids as well yeah the best of the Pirates
is the bestest Revitalize everything we loved
um the parts of the cinematography that's
semi-concern me is when it's live like here
yeah when or what like why is it like this gray
washed out color about the colors yeah and I was
not on the train of people when that poster
dropped of like oh it's too dreary looking
like there's certainly moments to look yeah
they put that poster on there people color
correcting it and going see this is what real
color saturation looks like but you know I mean
when they're getting you know thrown around by the
waves it's plenty dreary but yeah that's a Quant
that qualifies for that scene yeah but when you
you juxtapose yeah the CG heavy stuff with some
of this more tangible location shooting I think
all of it has sort of a weird like there's some
element of saturation that does feel like it's
maybe a little bit missing and I can't tell if
it's if it feels grayed out or if that's some kind
of choice that they make it looks great out to me
yeah I'm on that side right now because I think
I understand when you have to make it a little
darker when you're under water and stuff because
you're making up for a lot of this visual effects
which does look I mean to me it looks pretty
good right now sure um the hints that we've got
of Ursula I think are pretty cool uh she's really
seems like she's bringing her to life uh I'm I'm
not distracted by the fact that it's Melissa
McCarthy because I thought it was going to be
I thought it was gonna be more Melissa McCarthy's
dropping a bunch of jokes stuff like that yeah it
seems like she's paying respect to it the thing
though is is that something with the visuals it's
like they don't look underwater it looks like they
they they're not under water they they put water
effects around you yeah you know it looks like
they put things like little particulates in the
foreground and then they really got everybody's
hair to do that sort of weightlessness thing yeah
that was one of my big concerns and and I get
that James Cameron can't just direct everything
water related after something like the way
of water anything that takes place in a deep
sea environment like this you kind of it begs to
feel that immersive and some of these underwater
shots unfortunately do feel a bit green screeny
yeah I mean it looks like the colors are really
popping in in this particular sequence here sure
yeah it was one of these it was probably like a
musical number yeah not even sure what musical
number this is supposed to be is it under the
sea perhaps all the different creatures thought of
every other musical number with that one yeah yeah
hey you know I mean yeah that's I'm sure a primed
Disney fan will be like actually no if you go back
to the animated movie it'll probably correlate to
this but yeah yeah I mean it's got a interesting
look because yeah I mean it's the it's the little
mermaid right right now what they're showing us
is The Little Mermaid movie yeah it's just the the
visuals themselves have this mixture of going for
embracing the fantasy sometimes just straight up
looking like an animated movie other times they're
trying to go for the realistic dark grittiness
uh and then they go for some of the animals for
that Lion King prehistoric Planet Apple TV effects
absolutely sure it's just this hybrid of a bunch
of different and I'm wondering like is it is it
is the visual experience going to gel other is
it gonna be wonky yeah and I'm and I'm fascinated
to find out because Rob Marshall I don't always
I feel like in some ways he knows how to do a
musical and stuff like that I don't love every
ear Mark of his Direction style four musicals
but this does look very sweeping and classic and
like you know a big costume and locations kind
of period yeah mixed with an undersea fantasy
both of those elements I think are exciting
uh but at the same time yeah I'm not I I don't
know like this seems like a big undertaking for
somebody like to adapt The Little Mermaid into
live action seems like something you would need
both a person who really understands musicals for
but also someone who's like a technical whiz and
I don't associate yeah so he's done a lot of big
Productions like into the woods and everything
but I don't I I'm with you on that side of oh
when it comes to the visual effects Department he
hasn't really done anything where I'm necessarily
jazzed by what he's produced like this looks like
an animated movie right here yeah like this part
with Ursula this is straight up just 2D animation
yeah it does and this this was the most exciting
passage of the trailer along with like seeing all
the different creatures in The Ensemble together
yeah like Ursula really pulls me in in a way where
I felt like if this was you know some kind of live
stage adaptation they were like Melissa McCarthy's
gonna step in and play Ursula I'm like that's a
cool step for her as an actor to show off her show
tunes chops and maybe reign in some of her unique
isms to embody this character and I mean how uh
Hallie looks uh you know perfectly charismatic
as Ariel but I also really want to kind of get to
know her through this uh yeah I didn't feel like
I really got a sense of any of the characters
much more than stoic Trident yes yeah Trident
that's all I really got to understand but anyway
uh yeah this was a fine trailer sure but uh what
did you guys think about it did you did you like
it I mean it's suitable yeah it's it's a little
mermaid trap I was weirdly more enhanced by the
uh entrance by the because like I think I think
like the the vocal sound great like everything
sounds great uh but I was more weirdly jazzed by
the small teaser trailer I know I think it's just
that promise of your imagination gets to fill in
all the rest yeah you see it here and you're like
this kind of looks like it's getting there yeah it
looks a tad in Conflict what's up who knows could
be could be worthwhile uh anyway guys leave your
thoughts down below uh be sure to subscribe leave
a like and uh we will catch you all soon foreign